haven't learned any tik-tok dances yes I
have my daughter did teach me some about
doing them come on
my name is George Motz and it's my job
to celebrate the regional American
hamburger I like hamburgers just like
you regional burgers are everywhere
which means that there's a certain
regional identity to a hamburger in many
parts of the United States guys bubble
them you see that bubble come on mouth
when you get into the regional America
hamburger you're actually getting into
history and you're learning about where
these burgers come from in a way we're
actually learning all about who we are
as Americans today I'm gonna teach you
about a regional icon from Hawaii
yes Hawaii the loco moco when you think
of a Hawaiian burger unfortunately I
think you're probably if they can get
pineapples you're thinking of ham yeah
you ready for this one
it wasn't even invented in Hawaii the
pineapple on a burger was actually
started in Ontario Canada not kidding in
Canada not Hawaii if you go to Hawaii
and you ask for a pineapple on a burger
you'll give you one and then it'll be
chuckling in the kitchen is there
thinking this guy thinks he knows what
he's talking about
but it makes me angry first I think
pineapple on a burger is yeah it's too
sweet well why would you want to put a
big ring of grilled sweetness it's
disgusting don't do it people it's too
sweet a real homegrown Hawaiian burger
is unquestionably the loco moco it's
actually not even really a hamburger I
like to include it in the hamburger
family hamburger something you could
pick up with your hand and put in your
face this is one of the burgers that I
approve up you can actually eat with a
knife and a fork there are four elements
to a loco moco it's a bed of rice on a
plate the hamburger patty on top of that
covered in brown gravy and then there is
a fried egg on top mmm I have a lot of
apparatus here you can see I've got a
rice maker
I'm gonna flattop for making a burger
I've got a pan for frying an egg stand
back
basically I'm making a smash burger on a
flattop a little bit of salt
I like making a fried onion burger so
I'm actually adding onions to the burger
the same way they would have done it in
Oklahoma smash into the burner these
onions are sliced paper thin so they
cook faster I think I need to take
forever to cook rice on the plate I've
got my handy rice cooker over here this
is a gift for my kids for Christmas one
year they also one year gave me a beer
holder for my shower which I use this
burger was actually invented by a
football team and I think you probably
understand why a lot of protein here the
burger speaks to you it tells you when
to flip it it's saying clipping you want
to make sure you fry egg perfectly you
have to have a runny yolk
okay now the burgers done burger on to
rice now gravy so now we have rice
hamburger patty gravy and now the fried
egg goes on top this is on fire okay
fried egg on top oh oh look at that
oh wait over here you see that a little
lower closer to my heart
[Music]
it's a locum oh look at that thing you'd
probably imagine this is very popular
with late-night crowd in Hawaii it's a
great late night snack look I won't go
eaten with a fork I'm gonna break the
yolk ready here we go
break yolk oh look at that
bleep beer get shut of that get in there
mmm Oh give you a hot sauce
work the loco moco mmm oh that's [ __ ]
good
is it a burger not really it's a
hamburger plate which actually goes back
to the beginning of the hamburger if you
think about it in Germany where
hamburgers were not served on buttons or
bread Oh start going to plate just like
this just not with rice in an egg and
gravy on tap
no is it good oh oh yeah is it in the
hamburger family definitely is it a
hamburger
not really and it's Hawaiian a real
Hawaiian burger not a pineapple in sight
see you next time
[Music]
I could literally drink this Wow
you could drink it too but Ted knows
well it's pretty intense
[Laughter]